[Music]
in the blink of an eye six glorious
episodes of the falcon and the winter
soldier are now behind us
let's take a look into some of the
characters we've come to know over the
season
and why they mean more than you might
think
we first met carly morgenthau in episode
one as a masked flag smasher
with what appeared to be superhuman
skills she proved to be a super soldier
in episode 2
and we found out that she was the leader
of the flagsmashers
a group trying to get the world back to
the way it was before the blip
when it comes to carly in the comics
well there's no such person
at least not directly cardi was based on
a comic book character with almost an
identical name
carl morgenthau aka flagsmasher karl's
first appearance on the comics was in
captain america issue 312
and he was a violent opponent of
nationalism unlike kali karl was not a
super soldier
only highly skilled in martial arts
especially karate
while we could have seen a lot more from
carly given carl's history in the comics
she met her end in episode 6 by the
hands or gun
of sharon carter unfortunately for the
flag smasher
super soldiers are not immune to bullets
and cole's legacy in the mcu
is now over we meet john walker in the
conclusion of episode 1
as he's being introduced to the world as
the new captain america
fans had a hard time accepting the new
cap especially when he became a
murderous lunatic in episode 4.
we did get a bit of redemption for john
though he checks himself during episode
6's big fight scene
where he opts to save the grc hostages
rather than beat up on some flag
smashers a little more
we see him finally become us agent at
the end of the episode
officially given the title by the
charismatic contessa valentina allegra
de lafontaine
in the comics john first appears in
captain america issue 323
he has first introduced a super patriot
who later becomes captain america
and is eventually named a us agent the
name he now holds in the mcu
usage is more of a morally ambiguous
character in the comics
living in shades of grey sometimes
helping our heroes and sometimes
fighting against them
he also works directly for the
government but that doesn't appear to be
the case for the character in the mcu
since we still don't really know what
valentina's deal is he did once lead the
west coast avengers in west coast
avengers vol
2 issue 44-45 a possible future role for
our mcu character
the death of the mahaskins is definitely
one we didn't see coming
and it was just as much of a devastating
blow to the viewers as it was to john
walker
okay maybe not as devastating but one of
the only people keeping walker in line
was lamar who we assumed would have a
solid future in the mcu
as he's got a solid comic's history to
work with first appearing in captain
america issue 323
lamar was a wrestler who like his friend
was granted superhuman abilities by the
mysterious power broker
after john is dubbed the new captain
america lamar becomes the new bucky
barnes
a loyal sidekick to the so-called hero
he eventually takes on the moniker
battle star
a force for good who was a part of
several superhero teams including the
underground the ducky dozen and silver
sables wild pack
it looks like lamar's inclusion in
falcon and winter soldier
was to serve as a sacrifice that would
ultimately push walker over the edge
and we're now left with a thought of
what could have been since he was a
solid hero
during his stint on the comics while
battle star might not have as
complicated a history as his friend john
in the comics
he could have kept the us agent in check
and we suspect he'll need to be kept in
line again in the future
mckean torres has been a ride-or-die
ally to sam wilson since episode 1.
we always suspected he was going to have
a future in the mcu
giving his substantial albeit relatively
new history in the comics
and when sam left him his old broken
down wings we knew it was just the
beginning
we only got a brief glimpse of him in
episode 6 as he listens to some speech
to the senators in the grc
but it's definitely not the last we'll
see of him the character was first
introduced in captain america sam wilson
issue 1
as a teenager who was kidnapped and
experimented on with
dna from falcon's red wing an actual
bird in the comics
this turns were keen into a falcon human
hybrid with him eventually taking on the
mantle of falcon
after sam becomes captain america it was
clear this is where things were going
after sam left his old wings for his new
power behind
and where keane's coming past could hint
at him joining the mcu's rumored young
avengers team
now that sam is officially captain
america at the end of episode 6
it's time to name his replacement as
falcon
we first met george batroc and captain
america the winter soldier
as an adversary of captain america on
the hostage-occupied shield ship
the two men fought hand to hand cab
tossing his shield to the side
with bad truck coming out on the losing
end he was back in all his villainous
glory in episode 1
and reappeared in episode 5 to give kali
and the flag smashers some high-tech
weapons for the upcoming attack on the
grc
batroc is only interested in killing sam
wilson and gets his chance in episode 6.
he is unsuccessful and is himself later
shot and killed by sharon
known as batroc the leaper in the comics
the villain first appeared in tales of
suspense issue 75.
batroc is a mercenary and former member
of the french foreign legion
who excels in surveys a form of french
kickboxing
that focuses on the feat mostly an
adversary of captain america
bad truck has worked for hydra and has
kidnapped sharon carter
and also briefly worked for zemo batroc
has some altruistic moments in the
comics where he actually works alongside
captain america and falcon
such as in tales of suspense issue 85
however for all intents and purposes
he's mostly a villain
unlike so many other characters we met
in the falcon and the winter soldier
ayo and the dora melange were not new to
us having first appeared in captain
america civil war
move or you will be moved while her
first appearance in this series has calm
her second is decidedly nuts she lays
the smackdown on john walker and lamar
hoskins with two
other dora melange a group we also first
saw in black panther
in the comics adora melange or a small
group of female warriors who are the
personal guardians of the current black
panther
io nakia and okoye have all served in a
prestigious group
though the latter two are no longer
involved in the comics io is currently a
member of the midnight angels
a group of the dora malay who first
appeared in doom war issue 5
in 2010 this group joined deadpool in
combatting victor von doom
a notable fantastic four villain who was
rumored to appear in the mcu going
forward
this could mean this isn't the last we
see of io if the marvel studios writers
keep with her comic history isaiah
bradley's story in the falcon in the
winter soldier
is just as devastating as that of his
comics counterpart
isaiah gives sam wilson a crash course
on his life as a soldier in the united
states army where he was experimented on
and became a super soldier himself
and actually fought the winter soldier
in 1951
first appearing in truth red white and
black issue 1
isaiah was one of 300 black soldiers
experimented on
in an effort to perfect the super
soldier serum that was a success on
steve rogers
only a handful of men survived including
isaiah
and he eventually stole a captain
america uniform and escaped to europe to
fight in the war
he was imprisoned by the u.s government
for his treasonous actions
and served 17 years in solitary
confinement
before he was released and pardoned by
president eisenhower
isaiah's backstory in the comics is
based on the real-life tuskegee syphilis
experiment a racist and scientifically
unethical medical study conducted by the
united states government
it saw 600 black men tricked into
thinking they were receiving free health
care to treat
quote bad blood when in actuality they
were being observed
to see how their syphilis would progress
in an attempt to study the disease
then men who were sick with syphilis 399
of them as 201 men were in a control
group
were left to suffer without treatment
causing many to go blind
insane with some even dying as
researchers looked on
eli bradley made brief appearances in
three episodes of the falcon and the
winter soldier
when sam wilson and bucky barnes went to
meet isaiah bradley in episode 2
and when sam went back to baltimore in
episodes five and six
not much has said about eli in the
series as he sort of just looms in the
background
but eli's story from the comics is quite
an impressive one
there is definitely a chance we see more
of eli moving forward in the mcu
possibly in connection with the rumored
young avengers first appearing in young
avengers issue 1
eli is the grandson of isaiah and faith
bradley and the son of sarah gale
since sarah was born before isaiah
received the super soldier serum
eli is without superhuman ability but
that doesn't stop him from becoming a
hero
eventually given the name patriot eli
founds the young avengers which includes
speed and wiccan
the children of wonder maximoff and
vision we met in one division as tommy
and billy
the young avengers also includes kate
bishop who is to be played by haley
steinfeld in the upcoming disney plus
hawkeye series
just a brief appearance of eli and fours
could mean big things for the mcu going
forward
stoking the fire of the rumored young
avengers storyline that could launch in
phase 5.
in a move virtually no one saw coming
episode 5 of the falcon and the winter
soldier
introduced us to contesta valentina
allegra de la fontaine
played by julia louis dreyfus i know
it's hard
but i don't like to repeat myself so you
can just call me val
after giving john walker a brief talking
to val takes off not to be seen in the
series again
but we know it's not the last we'll be
seeing of her especially since she
mentions
she'll be calling john contessa
valentina allegra de la fontaine
first appears in strange tales issue 159
from 1967. once a former sleeper agent
of the russian leviathan
valentina eventually became an agent of
shield and the lover of nick fury
she also led the femme force a group of
elite female agents who were introduced
in captain america
issue 144 and were formerly led by
sharon carter
valentina's background is complicated
with her being a triple agent
working for the leviathan shield and
hydra at one point
she has even been dubbed madame hydra in
the comics but her loyalties were never
to the famous organization
and where her true loyalties lie remain
foggy
sharon carter's presence and the falcon
in the winter soldier seemed odd
and many believe she was a power broker
from the get-go it turns out all the
theories were true as sharon was
revealed to be the mystery character in
episode 6. we think
some are suggesting she isn't as she
never confirms carly in batroc's
comments
so we'll just have to keep guessing
until we see her again
nevertheless the power broker is a
marvel comics character
with quite the rap sheet first appearing
in machine man issue 7
the power broker aka curtis jackson is
the leader of the corporation
and later forms his own group power
broker incorporated
his business was strictly to profit from
making super soldiers
he is killed by the punisher another
character who might rejoin the mcu one
day
first appearing in tales of suspense
issue 75
sharon carter has no connection to the
power broker in the comics
she is a force for good but has once
worked for general thunderbolt ross
a character many had also suspected to
be the power broker throughout the
season
if these two are working together
remains to be seen but their ties in the
comics suggests it's a definite
possibility
ross could very well be on the other end
of the phone in episode 6's end credit
scene
we have not seen the last of baron
helmut zemo and that's a fact
the last we saw of the dancing menace
was an episode 6's finale when he was
catching up on some reading in his raft
cell
he seems happy to hear over his radio
that the remaining flag smashers have
been murdered
putting an end to all super soldiers on
earth interestingly enough it was his
adorable butler esnick
who planted the bomb inside the armoured
car that was transporting the remaining
villains to the raft
based on what we know of zemo's
backstory from captain america civil war
and what we saw in the falcon and the
winter soldier we can make some educated
guesses on where his story might be
heading
first appearing in captain america issue
168
zemo's got quite the backstory in marvel
comics
two of his biggest roles in the comics
include his position of leader
of the masters of evil such as in the
avengers issue
273 and founder of the thunderbolts
such as in the incredible hulk issue 449
the masters of evil were a true terror
for both the avengers
and the guardians of the galaxy z-mode
thunderbolts actually housed former
masters of evil members
the thunderbolts are a team of reformed
criminals that turned on zemo
and became heroes in thunderbolt's
annual from 1997.
it's possible that zemo will create the
thunderbolts in the marvel cinematic
universe
which might lead to his own downfall
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite
marvel shows are coming soon subscribe
to our youtube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one